-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome,
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here, you made it.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I can see everyone's
in a good mood.
That's right, 'cause today
Amazon kicked off
their second Prime Day event of
the year.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. Yeah.
It's that special event
that only happens once
every twice a year.
That's what I say.
[ Laughter ]
For Prime Day, I saw Amazon
was offering discounts on
DNA test kits.
It's for people who want to know
who their father is,
but not enough to pay
full price, you know?
[ Laughter ]
Amazon's also offering
huge deals on Pelotons.
Or you can wait three months
and get the company for free.
[ Laughter ]
It's up to you.
They also have deals
on smart watches,
cocktail shakers,
and knife sets.
So it's a great day to save
if you're James Bond.
[ Laughter and cheers ]
Guys, speaking of movies,
I heard that Tom Cruise
is set to film a movie in space,
becoming the first civilian
to walk outside
the International Space Station.
Yeah. Even crazier, the movie is
"Jerry Maguire 2."
[ Laughter ]
"Do you know the human head
weighs zero pounds in space?"
[ Laughter ]
"Help me help the moon.
Help me to help the moon."
[ Laughter ]
It's a big deal. When they
heard, the Space Force was like,
"Oh, come on.
We haven't even gone up yet.
Come on,
this is getting insane.
Let us do something."
Let's get to some news. Today,
President Biden and other G7
leaders held a virtual meeting
with Ukrainian president
Zelenskyy and pledged to support
Ukraine for as long as it takes.
Yep, nothing says "we're totally
here for you" like
a Zoom meeting
from 5,000 miles away.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Totally. We're here.
We're here for you."
But Biden promised Zelenskyy
that the U.S. will continue
providing Ukraine with the
support needed to defend itself.
It was a strong, powerful
message, until the other leaders
said, "Joe, you're on mute.
Joe? Joe?
You're on -- press --"
[ Applause ]
"We can't hear. Press mute.
We can't --"
Meanwhile, today, a top British
spy official said that Russia
is running out of ammunition.
That's pretty bad.
Right now their best strategy
is, "What if we deliver Ukraine
giant fun doll, and in doll
is another doll, and in that
doll is another doll,
and inside that doll --
wait for it --
it's just me saying, 'my bad'?"
[ Laughter ]
Guys, people are talking about
this. After Saudi Arabia worked
with Russia to cut
oil production,
Biden has decided to re-evaluate
the country's relationship
with the U.S.
Yep. When they heard,
Tom and Gisele was like,
"Oh, it's over."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I just saw that North Korea
just released images of
Kim Jong-un overseeing
a missile launch.
And one of the photos really
caught my eye.
Take a look at this.
Yeah, can we zoom in on --
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
He looks like he ran nude
through an Ann Taylor loft.
[ Laughter ]
It's that hot new look this fall
season, coastal dictator.
[ Laughter ]
He looks like a beekeeper
on his lunch break.
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys see this?
A lot of Dunkin' Donuts
customers are outraged over
changes to
their customer rewards system,
saying the perks aren't as good.
Well, Dunkin' just issued
a response.
Take a look at this.
-You gotta collect a few more
points to get a free coffee?
Cry me a Charles rivah, pal.
We didn't get a location every
five feet on the Freedom Trail
by handing out free coffee.
You want to talk problems?
We've had two shift supervisors
call out today, so that means
Janelle's gotta close
and she never restocks
the sugar packets.
So go ahead, go to Starbucks.
Go look your father in the eyes
while drinking a caramel ribbon
crunch frappuccino, 'cause he's
got the same points system we
do, and it's right between
his ring and index finger.
Dunkin'. You want "sorry"?
Go to Tim Hortons.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Tim Hortons?
Guys, get this, I read that
AstraZeneca's new COVID vaccine
nasal spray just suffered
a major setback
in its first human trial.
I'm just worried this could ruin
their reputation as the fourth
best vaccine option.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, AstraZeneca said the
initial testing on humans
did not yield
the desired protection.
Basically, they invented
the Tom's Natural Deodorant
of vaccines.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, guys, it's Tuesday,
it's time for "WeTweet."
Here we go!
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that we should
post on Twitter.
I'm gonna show you five
different tweets, and we're all
gonna vote on whether you like
each one or not.
You all have voting clickers at
your seats.
See them?
Yeah, there you go there.
You can vote for all of them,
you can vote for none of them,
whatever you want.
And we're gonna see the results
live right now.
Higgins, you got one?
-Got it.
-Roots, you have your clickers
too? Tariq?
-Got 'em.
-Whatever tweet gets the most
likes, we will tweet it out
live on the show
so that you can all like it
and "wetweet" it.
[ Audience ahs ]
It's a shared experience.
Alright, you guys
ready for this?
The first tweet is...
Yeah, there you go.
Alright. Quest, you're going to
press thumbs up just to be nice?
-I like my job, man.
-Yep, alright.
Higgins, what are you going to
give it?
-You don't wanna know.
[ Laughter ]
-You don't think that's the one?
-I don't, I don't.
-Alright, it's the first one
out.
-This is a tester.
-They don't necessarily get
better.
I'm just gonna say this.
[ Laughter ]
Just so we know
right off the bat.
Okay, one in the middle might be
better than this.
Who knows?
-We don't know.
-Alright, but we kind of know
the results here.
Everyone is just stunned.
They already pressed down.
They're, like, looking at me.
But let's see the results
so we know this is
real and not -- Wow.
-Wow. Wow!
-Wow!
That might be the worst one
we've ever done.
-41, that's a record.
-Alright.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoo!
-You guys don't have to be
that honest, okay?
It's up to you.
Humans did write those jokes.
I mean, they have feelings
as well.
-Don't be cruel.
-Alright.
This next one is, "I'm not
scared of heights
but I am scared of when
my waiter takes my order
without writing anything down."
[ Laughter ]
"No, no, no, I'm good,
I'm good.
Yeah, yeah.
No, yeah, you want it medium?
Okay, yeah. No problem.
No, I'll remember.
Yeah, okay, yeah.
And you want that? Okay.
Okay, no, no problem,
no, I'll remember.
Yeah, you want a side of that?
Okay. You can't have that?
Okay. Is there any allergies?
Alright, I got it. I got it.
No, I got it."
Let's see the results.
Oh!
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now you're being nice.
I love you guys.
-Wow, that was backlash.
-You guys are being so nice.
Thank you.
-That was like
a whiplash effect.
-That was too nice 'cause that
wasn't even that funny.
They're just being nice.
-I feel guilty, yeah.
-But I love that you did that.
There's a lot of love
in this room.
-They went, "This makes sense."
-This is good. I like this.
I mean, that's the extremes
right there, yeah.
Alright.
This next one here says...
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh. Spicy.
-"A sensual back scratch."
-Mm.
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah, come on. Why not?
I don't know.
-Come on. Mother Earth?
-Who knows. Mother Earth?
I love Mother Earth.
-Yeah.
-"Sensual back scratch."
-Yeah, I love it.
-That makes me laugh.
"Sensual" makes me --
Alright, let's see the results
on this one.
Yeah, yeah,
that's what I thought.
Alright, good, not bad.
[ Applause ]
Not bad. On other nights that
would have won.
-Yeah.
-But not tonight, no.
Alright, how about
this one here?
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-I don't know.
-Is this called "WeedTweet"
or "WeTweet"?
-No, not "weed" --
not "WeedTweet."
-Not "WeedTweet"? Okay.
-No, "we."
-"WeTweet." Okay, got it.
I'm voting.
-"Napkins should be called
lapkins."
-Right.
Because they go on your lap.
-That's correct.
-Right.
Not chinkins, yeah.
-Alright.
I think I know where
this one's leaning.
Alright, let's see the results
on this one.
Yeah, I agree, I agree.
[ Sad tuba]
I agree. Alright, here we go.
One last one to --
if we don't do this one,
then which one
are we going with?
We're going with the waiter?
-Yes.
-Yeah, we're going with
the waiter one.
If not, then there's this one or
Alright, here we go.
The last one is...
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I mean,
that's pretty relatable.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I'm like,
"I know it's on that side.
I've been doing it for years."
You go, "No, it's not, it's on
the other side."
Alright. Here we go.
Let's see the results
on this one.
No, there we go!
It's the waiter.
We're going with
WeTweet number two.
[ Bell dinging ]
I will post this during
the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a "wetweet," and enjoy.
Thank you for the honesty
and the love.